字幕: Rikuto Murakami
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
（テルミン演奏開始）
（演奏終了）
（拍手）
音楽とは何でしょうか
演奏とは何でしょうか
音楽には構造があり
音の秩序があります
言葉で書かれた詩や小説のように
世界の見え方や感じ方を伝えてくれます
言葉に文法があるように
音楽にも音楽理論があり
秩序を示してくれています
音楽や言葉の秩序に乗せて
共感を呼ぶ表現が生まれます
しかし
秩序があれば それだけで
良い音楽になるわけではありません
良い音楽には 秩序から
ほどほどに逸脱した要素が
ほどよく備わっています
みなさんは テルミン演奏に対して
どんなイメージを持ちますか
おばけの登場シーンの音でしょうか
確かに
1940年代から1950年代の
ハリウッド映画では
恐怖のシーンや
宇宙人が登場する場面の
効果音として
テルミンが使われていました
ピアノやギター
オーケストラでは出せない
一風変わった 音楽の異端を演じてきたんです
はい それでは ここで
テルミンの演奏の音を聴いてみてください
２つ 音のサンプルをお持ちしました
（テルミンの音）
はい　まさに お化けの登場とか
恐怖のシーンを連想させる音ですね
狭い音程を揺らぐ音
悲鳴のような高いピッチ
震えのようなビブラート
まぁこういったものが特徴的でしたね
それでは サンプルの２つ目を
聴いてみてください
（テルミンの音）
みなさん どんな印象を持たれましたか
これ どちらも私が弾いてるんです
こちらの音楽は 美しさとか
慈愛ってなことを意識して
演奏してみました
まぁこのように テルミンというのは
弾き方が違うと ずいぶん印象が
変わってしまうもんなんですね
テルミンは アンテナと身体との
距離を変えることで
自在に音の高さを変えます
動作に敏感に反応し
ほんの１ミリ動くだけで
１ミリ分だけ 音の高さが変わるのです
テルミンは 音の高さの連続性において
アナログな特性を持っています
その特性を活かして
言葉を持たない 動物のうなり声のような音を
奏でることもできます
先ほど 音のサンプルで
聴いていただきましたね
ハチャメチャなフリーミュージックを奏でる
テルミンの音は
人間もその昔 １匹の動物だった
遠い昔の面影を
音で聴くようです
それは 野蛮で無垢な 音の塊のようで
エネルギーの塊のようであり
感覚がそのまま解き放たれた
無秩序な音
だからこそ テルミン演奏では
コントロールする必要があるんです
音の感覚を磨き
音楽の秩序に沿って やらないと
たちまち 無秩序な音になっちゃうんですね
音の変化の連続性において 自由であるだけに
あえて
不自由で縛ってやる必要がある
まぁこれは テルミン演奏に限らず
自由そのものにも
当てはまるかもしれませんね
私は2016年のコンサート出演中に
脳出血を患いました
幸い一命は取り留めましたが
後遺症で右半身に麻痺が残り
ろれつ障害もあります
以前は立って演奏し
右手で音を高さ 左手で音の大きさ
を変えていました
音の高さの制御は
極めて繊細な動作が求められます
麻痺した右手で これをやるには
ハードルがあまりに高すぎました
音量制御ならできるかもしれないと考え
思い切って 右手と左手の役割を
入れ替えてみたんです
まぁ ずいぶん無茶なことをすると
言われましたが
左利きテルミン奏者として
再起を図ってみたんですね
長年の演奏動作の記憶が
それぞれの腕に染みついています
古い記憶は 新しい動作を拒み 邪魔をします
いったん古い記憶をすべて捨てて
まっさらな 子どものような心で
一から 覚えなおしてみました
この
学び直しの取り組みを通じて
分かったことがあります
私にとってテルミン演奏とは
自由奔放 野蛮で無垢な音を
私なりのしつけ方で
美しい音仕立てていく
そして 聴く人に
共感していただくことなんだと
改めて実感しました
私にとって テルミン演奏とは
無限に広がる選択の中から
私の音楽の美へと続く 一本の道を探す
「旅 」なのです
それでは最後に テルミンの演奏を
もう１曲やってみたいと思います
秩序の象徴たる ピアノの伴奏にのせて
テルミンの演奏をしてみます
ドヴォルザークの「家路」です
お聴きください
（テルミン演奏開始）
（演奏終了）
（拍手）